audiences fell hard for 2004's The
Notebook but according to the director
the drama sometimes continued after he
yelled cut co-stars Rachel McAdams and
Ryan Gosling apparently clashed in front
of the entire crew Nick cassavetes told
VH1 they were really not getting along
one day on set Ryan came to me and
there's 150 people standing in this big
scene and he says would you take her out
of here and bring in another actress to
read off camera with me I can't I can't
do it with her I'm just not getting
anything from this now I hate you
producers call to clear the air meeting
after Gosling refused to shoot the big
scene with McAdams and it got off to a
rocky start the director explained they
started screaming and yelling at each
other they had it out I think Ryan
respected her for standing up for her
character and Rachel was happy to get
that out in the open the rest of the
film wasn't smooth sailing but it was
smoother sailing the two actors ended up
dating for a couple of years after
wrapping the notebook